ich kann z Glück präzise vorher sagen wer
jetzt auf die Bühne kommen wird anni Hartmann
ja es gibt zu wenig Frauen die politisches
Kabarett machen aber es gibt sie und Annie
hachtmann ist eine von ihnen sie hat begriffen
um gute Unterhaltung zu produzieren da braucht
man nicht nur Humor sondern vor allen Dingen
auch eine Haltung und mit ihrem Diplom und
Volkswirtschaftslehre hat sie bewiesen dass sie
auch noch über Hirn verfügt die drei großen h
Humor Haltung Hirn in einer Frau vereint das
macht neugierig das schauen wir uns an hier
danke schön hallo hi danke schön
hallo ich muss sagen ich kann dem Volker
nur zustimmen es gibt Dinge die sind total
überraschend oder haben sie am Freitag stand
in der Zeitung drin Soldaten sind mit ihrem
Beruf unzufrieden schau an wer hätte gedacht
dass töten auf Dauer nicht glücklich macht und
und gegen geistige Armut kann man ja wenig tun
gegen Altersarmut schon findet zumindest Frau
vonderlein ne denn sie haben es mitbekommen
sie plant ja eine Zuschussrente Zuschussrente
für Geringverdiener also wirklich für alle
Geringverdiener also für alle Geringverdiener die
35 Jahre lang ununterbrochen in die Rentenkassen
eingezahlt haben und der Witz ist schon mal echt
gut ne und wenn die dann noch privat vorgesorgt
haben also private Vorsorge ist ja so eine Art
Hobby von gering Verdienern ja das muss ein
Hobby sein leisten können die sich das nicht
und ja danke schön und wenn die dann
also 35 Jahre lang eingezahlt haben
und privat vorgesorgt haben und dann
im rentenalterner weniger haben als
800 € Monat dann bekommen die vom
stat den Restbetrag bis 850 € oben
drauf also ich sag mal so wenn
es wirklich Leute gibt die 35
Jahre lang eingezahlt haben und
privat vorgesorgt haben und als
trotzdem weniger haben als 800 € da
muss man das System an sich überdenken
dan aber Mut Mutti Merkel hält natürlich nichts
von der zuschusszrente ist klar deswegen wand
sich die Frau vonderlein gerade so an die
SPD ran denn haben sie mitbekommen wie die
SPD sich aufgeplustert hat bei dem Thema
ja ich weiß beim Gabriel sieht das immer
so aus aber der Gabriel das muss man do
sagen der Gabri der hat doch echt Talent
oder der Gabriel der weiß ja immer ganz
genau was die Leute hören wollen das weiß
der ganz genau und dann sagt er das auch und
so überzeugend der muss das nicht mal meinen
und der gabriel hatte jetzt festgestellt
oh Zuschussrente riesen Thea steige ich
ein ne und hat gesagt ja wir wollen das auch
aber bei uns müssen die 40 Jahre eingezahlt
haben und ich find schön weil jetzt planen ja
USI und Sigi USI und Sigi planen schon mal die
groß al die große Koalition der weltfremden
und ich finde ja was ich toll finde ist ja
die von derline das ist eine super Verkäuferin
oder ich finde das immer so irre wie die die
Sachen verkauft bei der klingt das immer
so fürsorglich haben sie mitbekommen wie
sie das Bildungspaket verkauft hat können sich
daran erinnern Bildungspaket dieser größte Flop
Flop der harz4v das hat diese re gemacht
die stand ja vor jeder Kamera mit ihrem
natürlichen Lächeln immer so die wackelt
ja immer so ein bisschen mit Kopf ne fragt
man sich ist die nicht ganz dicht doch die ist
ganz dicht man sieht nur da ist eine Schraube
locker und bei diesem Bildungspaket da
stand die ja vor allen Kameras und hat
immer da gesagt so die Kinder kriegen warmes
mittessen warmes mittessen warmes warmes warm
warmes Mittagessen die hat nie Mittagessen
gesagt hat immer gesagt warmes Mittagessen
warmes warmes warmes warmes warmes Mittagessen
ja damit man die soziale Kälte nicht so spürt ja
ja weil dieses warme Mittagessen bekommen
ja die 10% der Kinder die zufällig das
Glück haben in eine Schule zu gehen die
überhaupt eine Kantine hat und um dieses
warme Mittagessen zu finanzieren hat
man das Elterngeld bei harzfempfängern
gestrichen die bekommen jetzt 300 € weniger
im Monat aber 10 € für den Sportverein Glück
gehabt zwe man muss sich das klar machen
zweitt aller Einsparung beim Elterngeld
sind folgt bei Elter mit einem Einkommen
unter 1200 €. nur ein Drittel wurde bei
besserverdienen eingespart es sei denn und
das ist der Clue an der Geschichte es sei
denn die verdienen sowieso schon mehr als
2800 € im Monat dann bekommen die weiterhin
den früheren Höchstbetrag Elterngeld
1800 € Monat klingt unsozial ist auch
so schön ja schön unsere Familienministerin
Christina Schröder ne die hatte ja ein super
Argument für diese unsoziale Praxis Christina
Schröder hat gesagt gerade für gut verdienende
Männer muss es weiterhin Anreize geben in
Elternurlaub zu gehen auchch christinchen
christinchen das geht doch an der Realität
vorbei christinchen sind wir da mal ehrlich
wer sind denn gut verdiene Männer h gut
verdiene Männer sind Chefs und Chefs
gehen doch nicht in Elternurlaub Chefs haben
nicht Frauen Kind Chefs halten sich Frauen
Kind